on a réussi à la fin de l'année et si
vous nous a fait si vie dure à cette
dernière vous savez à quel point les
projets sont nombreux chez nous et on
peut les faire en partie grâce aux
marques comme nord bpn qui par exemple
sponsorise cette vidéo il ya un lien or
vnc le vpn avec plus de 14 millions
d'utilisateurs dans le monde ceci le
plus rapide du marché est l'un des seuls
disponibles sur toutes les principales
plateformes en français et sans accent
je vous en reparle très vite mais si
vous êtes curieux vous pouvez cliquer
dans le lien qui est dans la description
ou sur le lien c'est beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs ça vous permettra de
bénéficier d'une offre spéciale salit la
chaîne youtube oui je fais de vidéos
avec ma kad merad blog pourquoi parce
que on est en train de faire la saison 2
du blog sur la chaîne secondaire c'est
vous la connaissez pas le lien est
évidemment dans la description il ya au
minimum vidéo tous les quinze jours
depuis un an et demi maintenant grâce à
pauline qui fait le montage d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire que pauline a
officiellement intégré l'équipe avec des
sons tafel en cdi chez nous voilà ça me
fait plaisir mais j'avais déjà verre
poli et on s'est dit avec pauline est ce
qu'on ferait pas un petit best-of de la
saison une avec les images qu'elle n'a
jamais mis dans le blog parce qu'on se
disait c'est too much faut pas qu'ils
voient ça comme ça j'y suis allé ça
sentait déjà il faut pas manger un
sandwich énorme dit élégamment mais un
peu gênant avant d'enregistrer son livre
doit c'est parfait bah si c'est ce
qu'elle a fait elle a dit c'est une
bonne idée et elle a fait un méga
best-of de toute l'année la saison y
développe qu'on vous met ici sur la
chaîne principale après y'a pas que ça
se passe sur la chaîne secondaire ça et
à la fin de la vidéo vous avez des avis
des scènes coupées quoi à savoir ce que
ça vaut 1 là bas si pauline à les aider
à relever c'est pas pareil
j'ai aussi décidé d'écrire un nouveau -
dave perso et plus sûr du savoir que
j'ai et ça va être sur la manipulation
l usage des gentils jean ses terres en
restant dans le camp des gentils et j'en
ai déjà parlé à mon éditeur il est chaud
pour mot sucre comme ça me sortirait au
mois de mai il remplacerait un petit peu
le dernier livre en gc dans l'historique
ce serait mon cinquième bouquin dont
vous voir aussi si je peux écrire ce
genre de libre aussi vite
c'est maintenant on est à arcueil on
vient chercher le casse tête qu'on avait
commandé il ya de ça deux mois après
environ un an de discussions et puis
ensuite il faut se mettre d'accord sur
l'univers pour choisissons les
mécaniques pour viol etc nous ce casse
tête on l'a pas encore viola bouquet en
photo auprès des chambres et c'est
forcément le plus gros casse tête de la
chaîne c'est la photo et on a fait
beaucoup construire et penser à l'aps
tnt d'une société fait des systèmes de
dca ses souhaits donc voilà on va
récupérer tous à le ramener au bureau et
vous pousse à glace ne sais pas du tout
à quoi ils pressentent
lui il a besoin pour le tournage
c'est là
ceux qui ne boivent pas
là on a trop long
partis ont fait rage
[Musique]
alors nous voilà du tout de retour au
bureau est donc déjà on a galéré avec
faire passer par la fenêtre qui est là
et maintenant on s'est dit et mais on
n'a pas cette force pour reporter
jusqu'à du coup l'autre pièce avancées
disent on va prendre deux chaises d'un
ami le casse-tête dessus et on va
essayer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
ça
geo
fabien ne sais donc pas ce à quoi
ressemble le casse tête est là il vient
ma demande et du coup s'il pouvait avoir
juste une photo du coup je vais lui
envoyer
[Musique]
cette firme de pied
saluons née le samedi 30 il était
interpellé le programme de la journée ça
va être décrire être travaillé pas mal
en gros le goal du week end ces deux
quasiment terminée le prochain livre qui
sera sur la manipulation vous en avez
parlé mais je dois aussi préparer le
pilote dont de l'émission de france 2
avec michel cymes et on va recevoir
tirer lhermitte et je sais qu'il est
atteint de prosopagnosie en gros il ne
sait pas reconnaître les visages c'est
un problème du cerveau j'avais fait une
vidéo youtube sur le sujet qui s'appelle
3 troubles du cerveau ou un truc comme
ça donc que donc à ces deux choses des
affaires il ya un peu de travail
habituel bon a pas se mentir à commencer
par faire un petit café très très béni
sion à toutes et tous
[Musique]
allez devoir regarder
merci infiniment de temps silence les
amis bien sûr les portables sont coupés
4 3 2
[Musique]
mais quand on est 4 mars au 24 mars
salut il est huit heures du matin
aujourd'hui c'est une journée de matière
grise puisqu'on pour la première fois on
va tourner et de matière grise en même
temps et ça c'est parce que ça va
rentrer faut savoir quand même quelque
chose c'est que tout le monde est
toujours un peu de stress sur la matière
grise surtout on va pas se cacher loïc
qui le vit un peu en mode tu vénères et
fanny qui le vit en mode gemalto donc ça
c'est pour la matière grise habitudes en
tournage parce que c'est des tournages
assez dense alors qu'est ce que ça va
donner dans temps les deux dans la
journée on va voir ça aujourd'hui aller
tayeb taxi moto va arriver et direction
matière grise transition de blogueurs
nul
et qui ceux qui s'initient dans ce blog
le partenariat du genre vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure comme je vous le disais
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé
par north vn mais finalement ça sert à
quoi un vpn beaucoup d'entre vous savent
mais déjà pour résumer ça sert à surfer
avec plus de sécurité vous soyez dans
des wifi public dans un bar la fac en
voyage norvez elle protège votre
navigation avec nord et pn vous pouvez
aussi élargir votre catalogue de
contenus disponibles que ce soit sur la
télé ou en streaming mais aussi en terme
de jeux vidéo et en plus de ça vous
aurez un service qui en france est dispo
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 ainsi
qu'une garantie de remboursement de 30
jours est signé dans les pnc donc sans
engagement donc si vous cherchez un vpn
vous pouvez tester celui-ci le lien est
dans la description vous pourrez
également bénéficier d'une remise
importante pour une durée limitée club
salut je m'appelle fabian le cas dans ce
format que faisons un focus sur un an en
particulier du cerveau dans les épisodes
de ces temps vous avez proposé de parler
des sentiments décision d'un cerveau ces
deux sujets du jour bienvenue à matéri
alors ça donnait pas le passage que
encore aller on s'en crée une petite
à laisser partir
le cas réels oui toutes les parties solo
de l'émission 6 sont rentrés exact sauf
le partenaire ce sera parce qu'on
pourrait pas bloquer un petit peu le
moment on va faire les partenaires parce
que c'est un petit oui on peut faire ça
de dire que l'art j'avais tout déplier
j'ai des idées surtout j'ai compris une
chose que
je fais pour actifs notamment des sous
moi ce que tu manges
moi je pense chose du clan cet atout
mais le petit déjeuner et ses 52 pages
tu as le to7 style le cerveau des
dossiers un petit peu surtout si on
apporte au pouvoir c'est très
certainement de sa 12e rang
[Musique]
maintenant même ont relâché un métier
aussi deux comédiens cadre réalisateur
influenceurs blagueur
je suis avec mon petit léo klm moi je
peux du petit lait un mois c'est pour
moi c'est du petit lettre
salut
[Musique]
à tous
[Applaudissements]
c'est ainsi
excusez moi on en fait sa matière grise
oui
il a pas demandé d'être torse
tu peux la mettre et puis tu mais je
crois qu'ils auraient trop loin dans ma
sèche pas tu veux voir trop de bois de
salut nous sommes le 6 mars il est
7h30 8 actuellement ça fait un an jour
pour jour que j'ai pas joué sur scène et
b je me réveille en ayant quand même un
petit peu les boules voilà c'est donc
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup la scène de
vous retrouver après les spectacles
c'est bon là un an c'est long et puis on
sait qu'on n'est pas encore sorti tout
ça donc voilà que j'ai toujours eu
vraiment la peine et android mais là un
peu les boules aujourd'hui mais voilà
c'est une journée chargée c'est un
week-end chargé c'est une semaine
chargée tant mieux ça fait penser à
autre chose salut on est le mercredi 17
mars
et aujourd'hui je ressemble à un
schtroumpf déjà et on a prévu de monter
le décor de cabinet curieuse et ce alors
aujourd'hui on va monter le nouveau
décor
aujourd'hui
j'ai mes meilleures chemise c'est ma
chemise ou d'été la masse graisseuse
tacos qui sortent sur une pizza l'inter
stellaire elle fait mal au genou je suis
même leur chemise pour
m
demeure nous rappelons aux films
[Musique]
voilà tout
et voilà après 10h de trucs on a beau le
de ça maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est
des petits rapporter ensuite on mettra
en place le décor et on revient vers
vous avec de nouvelles de nouvelles
aventures décoratives
transition de blogueurs je sais pas ce
que les biens ont bloqué hier mais là en
gros si le studio que vous connaissez
l'angle de vue c'est celui-là voilà
c'est très classique mais maintenant en
face si on regarde on a le nouveau
studio d'un nouveau projet alors après
dans la réalité c'est vraiment juste ça
un studio c'est juste le bon angle au
bon endroit ce qui permet
d'avoir une pièce complète je trouve ça
je trouve ça stylet l'idc je lance un
nouveau format bientôt qui s'appelle le
cabinet curieuse le premier épisode sera
avec quoi sont faits qu'on s'adapte est
pas sorti quand le vlog sera sorti donc
soyez attentifs et donc ce sera dans ce
nouveau studio la vie aussi si vous
aimez ou pas cette ambiance les
particuliers
vous souvenez de ma vidéo sur la
chouette d'or voilà sinon regardez là ça
va vous briefé sur ce que c'est et donc
on avait rencontré le créateur on lui a
fait un interview en se disant et ça
peut nous servir dans une vidéo c'est la
vidéo qu'on est en train de construire
là on va rencontrer un chouette heures
c'est-à-dire un chasseur de la chouette
d'or depuis plus de 20 ans que la
chouette un tout petit peu plus de vingt
ans aujourd'hui on va la perdre y avait
ici on va faire plein de blocs comme ça
ça aura pris presque un an et à la fin
j'espère qu'on aura une vidéo champ mais
avec ça mais ça va être que quatre
bien bien l'énergique au travail alors
c'est ici qu'on va tourner la suite de
l'entretien avec du lien des dalles sont
en train jérémy de chercher la chouette
donc l
ici parce que moi je me connais très
très bien en chasse au trésor et si
elles deux lignes qui font un fixe je
sais je connais ça rassure et là vous
avez l'air de sipan nouvelle chef dans
le parisien oui j'ai un statut et en
dehors oui je vous ai 4000 euros
[Musique]
c'est une femme tournage pour
aujourd'hui on interdit d'enregistrer
donc la troisième à la troisième partie
mais dell et troisième élément de vidéos
qu'on avait besoin pour cette seconde au
cul sur la chouette d'or nous en reste à
à tourner et après on pourra passer en
phase de montage mais avant de tourner
vers nous il faut qu'on fasse la phase
ii des roches à l'écriture parce que cet
homme là et moi même avons été beaucoup
trop bavard mais c'est ça l'intérêt est
donc on a trouvé où il a choisi la les
six est faux
[Musique]
super c'est ma nouvelle casquette celle
était de mise
c'est cool c'est quoi la lozère comment
ça lui on est vendredi 23 avril on a
tourné les parties studio du deuxième
cabinet curieuse ce matin et là du coup
on est partis au bois de vincennes pour
faire les plans en extérieur de la suite
de l'épisode
[Musique]
le favori au vagin pour n'être qui se
recroqueville dès qu'il ya du soleil
le fab ou sauvages nous a vus
je vis ici depuis le vide
à savoir l'accès aux horaires de bus ont
tenté de travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont reçu deux balles dans la tête
non mais je connais j'ai cherché le
poteau sur
le fauteuil a été habité par un certain
jérémy
s'il est opposé
à le télétravail
ils ont besoin du fauteuil ouais j'suis
désolé
pourtant il vient d'écouter le dernier
podcast
c'est beaucoup trop encore
voilà je
joue tout seul les jeux je garde les
affaires
dans les bois
de vincennes
voilà voilà
nous sommes en body 30 avril réparation
de tournage et on a reçu un petit
quelque chose ça vous qu'est ce qu'on a
reçu aujourd'hui le vinyle de tout est
mia pour laisser le coffret des trente
ans c'est trop bien encore frais après
on a reçu aussi des liquides à vue pour
le matière grise 9 je crois que c'était
flurry potter il ventile possie
et du crew bien d'autres jeux patar
aussi un truc tôt loïc
on a reçu mon nouveau livre qui sort le
12 mai mais quand eux ils verront ce
blog des sorties regardez c'est là la
première fois vraiment qu'il arrive ici
dans ce bureau devant la taille ça si
vous les charges pause je pouvais dire
tout le livre vous avez le sommet est là
si vous mettez en 05 vous pouvez lire
l'intégralité du livre
voilà non en vrai je suis très très fier
d'eux si tu veux cet après midi je vois
pierre bock et on continue de travailler
sur le projet secret dont vous avez des
trucs qui dans le bloc 5 ça j'ai
vraiment hâte de vous en parler mais
comme je vous disais vous en parle pas
non pas pour vous cacher encore une fois
parce que c'est inédit ça s'est jamais
fait est vraiment j'aurais les boules
parce que j'en ai parlé dans un blog ça
existe avant celui que je sorte mais
vous allez trouver sachant mais de
pression
bonsoir je suis à filtrer sur un
tournage c'est bon
fabriquer quelque part par là
fini jérémy
c'est qu'un demi
après
[Musique]
je je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la fin de tournage fin de tournage
aujourd'hui bonjour j'ai l'impression
c'était long c'était dur
mais ça fait plaisir et le tournage à
c'était super sympa aussi
c'est le ba écoute moi ce que j'aime
bien les fin de tournage lyon est ce que
j'aime bien c'est bloqué sur les fins de
tournage comme ça je fais pas le
rangement et a par exemple la lie à
jérémy est en train de ranger et les
blogs sachez tranquille salut voila
bonjour il a bien travaillé [ __ ] bon
c'est pas fini parce qu'il faut encore à
écrire le livret avant mardi maintenant
on n'en parle pas de ça alors dit pas de
le projet secret sur lesquels on
travaille d'ailleurs ok mais on leur dit
ça tout ça s'est secrètement ses sacres
à craquer enfin reste comme ça mais faut
quand même que je le fasse oui
là pour le tournage embarcadère après on
lâche fabien comme ça ils sont là
ça marche aussi un bond des liens
bonjour
c'est actuellement au domaine de la pia
gronde on a passé la nuit là c'était
vraiment stylé de fou a bien dormi tout
dans la maison dior habite vachement
bien dormi mais les héros bruit c'est un
c'est impressionnant et puis sous la
terre toi tu étais bien désolé dans un
tipi indien
à l'air libre vous êtes bien des
pare-chocs la cour on a tourné hier
plein d'éléments pour la vidéo de la
chouette d'or vous avez déjà vu dans les
blogs et aujourd'hui on tourne les
éléments de cabinet curieuse 3 les
esclaves de l'île de tromelin avec doc
seven qui doit déjà être sorti sur la
chaîne principale secondaire suivez
aussi
[Musique]
et vous donc comme fabien vous le disait
on mais dans un endroit où il ya des
maisons de hobbit et à celle ci par
exemple est du coup passée les c'est
l'heure de partir qu'ils soient fiers
plus personne normalement on a quittés
on a rendu les chambres vers vers 13
heures donc logiquement ya plus pertes
[ __ ]
mais on est censé partir mais ils ont
refait la chambre et où najlae
dans la chambre qui est heureux mais je
ne partirai pas c'est trop tard je
démissionne au revoir à tous trois y
allez les gars on sortait de chez nous
monsieur là c'est quoi
sion
[Musique]
bat on repassera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'anneau
titane
olano
[Musique]
qu'on a voulu tourner vendredi dernier
qui s'est aperçu qu'il a oublié un câble
ou des cas les mêmes temps au domaine de
la pierre ronde où on est allé tourner
ouais c'est vrai il est allé en racheter
le temps de ce forum brouillée par un
mec il ya des petites choses sur les
épices matin on se fait une réunion avec
fanny et loïc comme on fait souvent
l'année et qui fit donc je lui qui dit
oui il faudrait qu'on achète des trucs
pour qu'on est en déplacement parce que
là comme on a perdu des câbles là par
exemple moi j'ai dit on a perdu des
cayes et si la fée patron de la société
verdict
c'est ses bâtiments et palatines ici en
bas si
c'est vraiment celle en soit c'est
l'entité tournage tu sais que c'est moi
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un et ça
s'appelle le biais cognitif de cohabiter
à savoir ça ira les sciences logiciel de
la personne en elle-même les problèmes
viennent de la communauté c'est fou non
ça existe sûrement mais là alors moi
maintenant je veux dire est ce que je
devrais me redire là on a fait un bon
montage n'atteint jolie que
sur les vidéos a cartonné les gens
étaient contents de la vidéo mais quand
un montage par deux tombons pas le duel
le oui mais pas deux si j'y songe 28
dedans dit jamais notre montage tu peux
dire on a bien fait sur les dauphins de
pervez sur ma bien fait et maintenant le
générique au pays de mauvaise météo
loïc la mauvaise foi qui c'est qu'a
perdu c'est qu'ils aient carré ici c'est
vous c'est moi c'est je le fais en toute
modestie c'est qui c'est qu'a perdu ici
passionné la team mauvais dort pas le
câble a été perdu mais comment il a géré
la faute sur le câble
il était trop bien les taux de maire de
la gaude omer
domaine de la pierre ronde il avait
envie d'y aller
[Musique]
michel
baylet il n'est pas là d'un match s m'a
donné
[Musique]
l'espace
le maquis j'ai pas confiance voilà c'est
bien matifier ça puisque les dix mois je
fais mais correct mais tu fais n'importe
quoi non mais vous savez là c'est mieux
mais c'est mieux de quoi passer quoi
dans critères de mieux c'est mieux pour
halloween pourquoi ranger le ca me ça
mais
surtout vous êtes des petits m'a dit
voilà
bientôt une chaîne de make up
your les cheveux différentes couleurs
dans l'oréal brisons les avances en
dessous on ouvre la chaîne de l'oréal
c'est qu'il va avoir très chaud quand tu
m'as sortir pourquoi parce que sa
fermeté port
ça pue du coup je suis là moins
maquillée de ce bureau finalement
je les nie aussi
du coup qu'est ce que vous faites pas de
ses contenus on va on m'a agressé des
trucs et on garde ce qu'imad mines amis
quand je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai
horreur de ça ça me met un seul quand il
me met un micro on ne sait pas pourquoi
on identifie pas et on est d'accord sur
le fait que c'est rien et moi ça me fout
dans un moral j'ai dû avoir un trauma
d'un enfant ce lundi matin au micro dans
le berceau c'est des soucis c'est bien
du souci ou si c'est bien du souci nous
sommes le 18 juin et c'est le jour du
spectacle c'est le jour où je reprends
les spectacles alors quoi gros stress
pourquoi déjà parce que ça fait un an et
demi que j'ai pas joué ensuite parce que
je ne sais plus ce qu'il ya dans le
camion compris c'est qu'on en fait j'ai
un camion de tournée avec tout le
matériel technique
et sa ferme à nico on n'a pas mis dedans
je ne sais plus qui restent ou parce
qu'elle était bien rangé ou pas et ça
c'est d'abord mon premier stress qui va
être réglé vers 13 heures ce que je
serai sur place et je regardais ça puis
après j'ai le stress du spectacle est ce
que tu me souviens bien c'est bien de
rejouer absence à ce sera dans un
deuxième temps mais d'abord est-ce que
j'ai bien tout matériel qu'il faut pour
point sur l chaud et enfin merci encore
un orgue op end avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo avec le lien qui est dans la
description normes et peine pas comme
cela fabien olicard vous pouvez obtenir
un abonnement de deux ans plus un cadeau
bonus avec une énorme réduction
n'hésitez pas à tester le service est
sans risque puisque au pire des cas ils
vous remboursent merci
nous sommes le 24 février je sors des
toilettes
non entre vous pue du cul ouais c'est
sûr parce que c'était toi c'était tout à
fait moi c'est toi c'est vrai je prends
le blème sera jamais c'est moi mais je
trouve tes copains c'est toi je cours je
continue mon enquête jamie est ce que
c'est toi qui pue du cul j'ai pas fait
pour toi aujourd'hui donc c'est dit
élégamment mais un peu gênant dany parce
que c'est toi qui plaît du cul moi je
dire j'y suis allée ça sentait déjà le
tu sais quoi est-ce que là ce serait pas
le siège du couple j'ai besoin d'un
échantillon du suspect numéro un
c'est parfait c'est vous c'est vous les
preuves sont contre vous donc le lagarde
vous êtes accusé depuis du cul
bonjour fabu bonjour 4e sommes nous le
jour où j'ai tout laissé tomber pour me
lancer dans la batterie là je me
reprends moby dick on est tout ouïe ils
durent très longtemps et j'ai peur qu'on
est passé dessus c'est bon de la change
vraiment ça c'est une demi-heure de
solos de batterie moby dick voilà peut
être le faire comme dans les led et les
garçons et d aller vous êtes près les
gars 1 2 1 2 3 4 là il y avait la pub
qui se lancer à la fin de la pub ça
faisait juste
[Musique]
et c'est bizarre japon
que j'ai que des références de sitcom
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce matin mais
ça c'est que j'avais rendez vous j'ai
dix-sept jours les personnes qui qui
produisent pour un projet en septembre
et après on a enchaîné avec un sandwich
grand comme un bus de votre taille et du
coup j'ai une conclusion à cette
histoire il faut pas manger un sandwich
énorme avant d'enregistrer son livre
audio parce que toutes les deux phrases
stadiers qui me dit j'entends à un rôle
que c'est un homme né dans l'hérault
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi si paul des guilis
c'est que les clics le kiki noms
serveurs boyard ils font ça fendrait
je sais pas du tout si ça marche
je sais sur tik tok une fois m'a fait
beaucoup rire
ça change la part de mon visage
c'est l'enfer de la mode c'est vraiment
super sympa tu es vraiment le plus beau
des mannequins loïc il est dans sa tenue
un petit peu et portuaire parce que il n
va falloir qu'il a des muscles mais
comme c'est pas très très bien
d'égaliser par tous je n'y fais pas bien
tout voir déjà à l'aise dans son corps
loïc à partir du moment où on voit que
ces gros bras
c'est là en faire de la mode c'est
vraiment super sympa tu es vraiment le
plus beau nadia bien fait pour toi la
lassitude hommes clash aussi
c'est fabien olicard
mais rien à dire mais vraiment rien à
dire regardez moi ça sujet pudeur d'auge
une tête bien carrés qui représente
l'intelligence des bras freine mais pour
plus de rapidité pour taper des choses
délivrance par exemple
des jambes permettent de se déplacer
jusqu'à vous pour aller voir le
spectacle
exactement un tatouage un tatouage qui
représente
dans mon peuple
un patois
un tatouage mais on ne dira pas ce que
c'est ce que c'est en rapport avec
ce qu'on peut appeler un bateau
vous avez ce qu'ils aient connu tout le
temps